What's important that you guys understand is who we're actually writing this content
for.
And a lot of people when they get into this business, into the rank and rent digital real
estate space, or may I say rent then rank digital real estate space, they're confused
because they think their content has to be perfect.
And I'm just coming off my last video telling you we need to get obsessed and we need to
get really good at the content, but what you guys have to understand is who we're actually
writing the content for.
And I'm gonna just have you think about it like this, okay?
If you are sitting there and your tree, a lightning, whatever, lightning came or the
wind came and your tree like cracked in half and it was leaning over your roof, and you're
looking to get it solved, you're looking to get a tree company to come out and remove
it, are you gonna go and search tree company near me and go read every word on that tree
company's website?
Are you gonna go and read every single thing about how to remove a tree and what processes
we use and what saws and all this extraction methods?
Of course not, right?
So what you have to realize is in the services that we talk about, in the services that I
recommend in module one of part one of digital landlords, which is looking for layups, which
is picking the right niche, okay?
We are going into services where people just need the work done, that's the point.
They're not going to read the content, they're not.
And I'm telling you right now, I always joke about this, but if you've got somebody who
is reading every word of your website, that person is very likely a serial killer.
Who reads tree service content or mold removal content or duct cleaning content, and I'll
argue if somebody calls me on a quote form and says, hey, I read every word in your content,
what is this?
I'm not even gonna give that to the business owner anyway because they're literally probably
on the hit list, okay?
Or on America's top ten, that's weird.
No one's reading this stuff, so who are we writing it for?
We're writing it for Google, we're writing it for the search engine, so we're writing
it so that when the search engine crawls our page, aka reads our website or our homepage
or service pages, they know what it's about.
They know that it's about the keywords that we want to rank for.
They know it's about concrete contractors, concrete near me, cost of concrete, concrete
my area, whatever the keywords are, we want Google to know that our website is about that.
So what I want you to do is take a deep breath.
This doesn't need to be perfect.
It does not need to pass, you probably had an English teacher like I did that was very
critical of making sure that it read properly and all these different things.
Now you have to make sure this does not sound like it was written by a robot, so you have
to give it some thought, and as we start getting an outsourcing, that's one of the things we
have to look at.
We have to make sure that it sounds like it's actually a human, but outside of that, it
doesn't need to be interesting.
It doesn't need to have voice, and the content writers that I've hired in the past, where
Pete, they've tried to overdo it and ham it up and have too much personality, it just
doesn't work.
So guys, take a deep breath.
We're writing this for the search engines.
Don't stress it too much.
Just make it sound like a human wrote it.
Do, and lastly, do not plagiarize.
If you plagiarize, it isn't going to hurt the person that you stole it from.
It's going to hurt your website, and you can run the risk of getting sandboxed, blacklisted,
whatever you want to call it, deplatformed from Google.
They do not like that.
Do not plagiarize content.
It is not worth it.
It is not worth even risking.
Those are the little tips I want to share, and in the next videos, we're going to talk
about actually writing the content.